der eiffelturm das wahrzeichen von paris
ein meilenstein der
architekturgeschichte
bei diesem zeitpunkt seiner erfahrung
brachte eiffelturm alle rekordern und
heute ein touristen hotspot
wir vergleichen den eiffelturm
mit einer modernen ikone der baukunst
dem tokyo sky tree der das ist wirklich
ein duell der giganten in der
japanischen hauptstadt nicht zu
übersehen der tokyo sky tree was auf
deutsch himmels baum bedeutet
der höchste fernsehturm der welt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
stolz hebt sich der baum aus stahl in
den himmel hat einen derart hohen turm
in einem der erdbeben stärksten gebiete
der welt zu errichten ist eigentlich
reine wahnsinn der eiffelturm in paris
und der sky tree zwei außerordentliche
türme was haben sie gemeinsam worin
unterscheiden sie sich wir nehmen die
ikonen in drei kategorien unter die lupe
wie aufwändig war es die giganten zu
errichten
features welcher mega turm hat die
innovative technik
und architektur welcher turm
revolutioniert die baukunst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frankreich 1887 für die weltausstellung
in paris wollen die franzosen ein neues
weltwunder erschaffen und damit das 100
jährige jubiläum der französischen
revolution feiern
die idee ein 300 meter hoher turm höher
als jedes andere gebäude dieser zeit der
bauherr gustav fl
fl hatte eine vision er wollte nichts
geringeres als eine revolution der
baukunst und
tatsächlich bricht der turm alle rekorde
zum zeitpunkt seiner erbauung ist er 301
meter hoch
[Musik]
und trotzdem ein leichtgewicht nur
10.000 100 tonnen im verhältnis zu
seiner größe revolutionär hey fels
brillante idee er verbaut stadt stein
einfach stahl genauer gesagt
7300 tonnen für das gerüst dazu kommen
zweieinhalb millionen nieten
um nach oben zu gelangen müssen die
besucher über 1600 stufen erklimmen oder
einfach in einen der aufzüge steigen
der eiffelturm hat nur eine aufgabe die
ganze welt in staunen zu versetzen
das unglaubliche der turm soll nach 20
jahren wieder abgerissen werden er ist
sozusagen die erste pop up konstruktion
der welt das konnte fl einfach nicht
zulassen er hat eine brillante idee um
seinen tod zu retten er macht sein
architektonisches meisterwerk zum
sendemast der zum ersten fernsehturm der
welt wird und zu dem wahrzeichen von
paris
am anderen ende der welt fast 100 jahre
später
tokio wächst rasant immer höhere
wolkenkratzer schießen aus dem boden
für eine reibungslose
rundfunkübertragung muss ein
gigantischer thurnheer im jahr 2011
schreibt der japanische tokyo sky tree
geschichte
mit 634 metern schafft es der höchste
sendeturm der welt ins guinness buch der
rekorde
[Musik]
allein die stahlkonstruktion wiegt
36.000 tonnen über drei mal so viel wie
der eiffelturm
das neue wahrzeichen der japanischen
hauptstadt besteht wie heutzutage üblich
aus stahl stahl beton und glas eine
treppe mit über 2.500 stufen ist er für
den notfall gedacht
die besucher fahren lieber mit
hochgeschwindigkeits aufzügen auf eine
der aussichtsplattformen
die tokyo sky tree ist ein
technologisches wunder der japanische
sky tree und der eiffelturm von paris
wir untersuchen verschiedene kategorien
runde eins der bau wie schwer war es die
giganten zu errichten der vergleich
beginnt an der basis dem fundament
paris 28 januar 1887 zwei jahre vor der
geplanten weltausstellung beginnen die
arbeiten am eiffelturm auf dem einstigen
militärgelände schon de mar
doch bereits wenige spatenstich nach
baubeginn das erste problem der boden
auf dem der turm entstehen soll ist
zeitweise überschwemmt der untergrund
schlammig
trotz vorheriger tests war sich nicht
sicher ob der boden seine gigantische
konstruktion auch wirklich trägt die
sorge ist berechtigt schließlich hat ein
zu weicher untergrund schon so manchen
turm in schräglage gebracht wie den
schiefen turm von pisa gerade mal ein
jahr nach baubeginn im jahr 1173 beginnt
der turm sich zu neigen
[Musik]
apa die architekten hatten damals nicht
bedacht dass genau an dieser stelle der
boden vor allem aus lockerem leben und
sand bestand
das hohe gewicht sorgt dafür dass der
boden absackt bis heute hat der turm
eine neigung von knapp vier grad genau
das macht ihn weltberühmt aber
[Musik]
bei der pariser weltausstellung will man
so eine aufmerksamkeit auf alle fälle
vermeiden
[Musik]
die bahnbrechende lösung jeder der vier
füße des turms ruht auf separaten
pyramidenförmig aufsteigenden pfeilern
die idee die basis auf diese art zu
stabilisieren revolutioniert die
fundament technik weltweit
doch es gibt ein weiteres problem
zwei turm füße sollen direkt am 10 ufer
stehen das heißt die fundamente müssen
tief ins flussbett verankert werden
ließ sich durch nichts und niemanden von
seinem plan abbringen seinem
revolutionären denkansatz verdanken wir
dass der eiffelturm auf festen beinen
steht
er verlässt abgedichtete metall kammern
in den fluss absenken in diese leitet er
druckluft damit die arbeiter den schlamm
ausleben können je mehr sie graben desto
tiefer sinken die kammern bis sie eine
feste kalkstein schicht erreichen
[Musik]
die kammern werden dann mit zement und
schotter aufgefüllt die basis für das
betonfundament
[Musik]
auf 10 seite reichen die fundamente 14
meter tief in die erde auf der anderen
seite 9
was für ein aufwand was für eine show so
etwas hat die welt noch nicht gesehen
die herausforderung schwierig die lösung
spektakulär der eiffelturm beeindruckt
in der kategorie fundament
auch in tokio haben die architekten des
tokyo sky tree mit beachtlichen
problemen zu kämpfen
der turm soll mehr als doppelt so hoch
werden wie der eiffelturm und das
ausgerechnet in einem erdbebengebiet
kein anderes industrieland ist so
erdbebengefährdet wie japan
fast täglich bebte die erde
allein die metropolregion tokio
erschüttern jedes jahr 60 bis 70
spürbare erdbeben
das schwerste seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen ist das erdbeben im jahr
2011 es löst einen mehr als 14 meter
hohen tsunami aus und die
nuklearkatastrophe von fukushima
japan und vor allem tokio müssen im
prinzip ständig auf das nächste beben
gefasst sein
erdbeben eine reale bedrohung der tokyo
sky tree braucht ein extrem sicheres
fundament und das soll ganz dem namen
nach wie ein baum tief im boden
verwurzelt sein
das design sieht drei schwerpunkte vor
an jeder ecke versenkten die ingenieure
massive staat fehle 50 meter tief im
boden der clou sie sind nicht rund
sondern bestehen aus einem gitter von
sternförmig angeordneten stahlplatten
im boden fächern sie sich auf wie die
wurzeln eines baumes
für zusätzliche stabilität sorgen
doppelt verstärkte stahl betonplatten
welche die wurzeln miteinander verbinden
zurück künste das prinzip ist genial mit
jedem meter bodentiefe steigt der
reibungswiderstand zu diesem fundament
technik ist weltweit einmalig
die architekten des tokyo sky tree wagen
einen neuen weg und finden eine
bahnbrechende lösung
beim thema fundament stehen sich die
beiden türme in nichts nach beide
standorte bieten spezielle
herausforderungen denen die ingenieure
mit spektakulären lösungen begegnen
runde zwei welche maschinen haben den
turmbau revolutioniert
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts gibt
es noch kein schweres arbeitsgerät wie
konnte shell seinen legendären turm
erbauen
der heikelste schritt die konstruktion
der ersten etage vier horizontale trag
balken sollen die vier füße miteinander
verbinden und das in 50 metern höhe
die notwendigen stahlträger wiegen 70
tonnen der fels brillante idee er nutzt
die führungsschienen der fahrstühle um
sie nach oben zu schaffen
er setzte einfach dampfbetriebene kräne
auf die schienen sie kletterten
sozusagen mit dem turm nach oben so was
hat die welt noch nicht gesehen
doch wie gelingt es ihm die riesigen
stahlteile exakt auszurichten
auch hier entwickelt gustave eiffel ein
ausgeklügeltes system
mit handpumpen bewegen die arbeiter
riesige hydraulik über sie bringen die
vier gigantischen turm füße in position
ein uralter trick sorgt dafür dass alle
auf der gleichen höhe sind eher fell
platz jetzt sand behälter zwischen
gerüst und metallkonstruktion die
arbeiter lassen sand heraus rennen bis
die pfeile auf der richtigen höhe
ankommen
haenni mit ist nun mit dieser
bahnbrechenden verbindung aus moderner
technik und uraltem wissen war es
möglich den eiffelturm zu brown
ein weiterer meilenstein geschafft die
restliche konstruktion ist im vergleich
dazu für fl ein kinderspiel
der bau des turms zur damaligen zeit ein
technisches meisterwerk
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert kommt
beim tokyo sky tree hochmoderne technik
zum einsatz
[Musik]
aufgrund der außergewöhnlichen höhe des
turms kann die kleinste abweichung von
den bauplänen die gesamte struktur
schwächen
der bau eines 634 meter turms ist in
jeder hinsicht ein hoch anspruchsvolles
projekt hier sind außerordentliche
präzision und technische innovation
gefragt
für die montage errichten die ingenieure
eine voll automatisierte
fertigungsanlage vor ort
sie setzen eine vertikal bewegliche
fabrik genannt super construction
factory auf die spitze während des
bauprozesses wächst diese fabrik
geschoss für geschoss nach oben ein
roboter kümmert sich um die präzise
justierung der stahlträger auf den
betonplatten ein laser gleich die
plandaten ab damit alles exakt passt
einfach unglaublich was heutzutage mit
hilfe moderner systeme und robotik alles
möglich ist
der tokyo sky tree wächst durch die
obenauf sitzende fabrik wortwörtlich
stück für stück in den himmel
die ingenieure mussten sich einigen
herausforderungen stellen sie
kombinierten die zur verfügung stehenden
mittel mit neuen ideen in beiden fällen
ist das ergebnis revolutionär
letzte runde in sachen bau die logistik
wie lange dauerte jeweils der turmbau
paris 1887 das fundament steht dennoch
herrscht enormer zeitdruck in knapp zwei
jahren findet die weltausstellung statt
bis dahin muss der eiffelturm fertig
sein
[Musik]
ein ambitionierter zeitplan denn die
mega bauten der vergangenheit glänzt
nicht gerade in sachen bauzeit
die cheopspyramide
140 meter hoch 20 jahre bis zur
fertigstellung
der kölner dom nach rekordverdächtigen
632 jahren bauzeit eingeweiht
das 160 meter hohe washington monument
in den usa braucht 36 jahre
um den prozess zu beschleunigen lässt fl
den kompletten turm in seinem firmensitz
in level up entwerfen und vorproduzieren
eifel war sozusagen der erfinder des
baukastenprinzips
seine arbeiter fertigen die 18.000
einzelteile des turms eigens an auf den
zehntelmillimeter genau
[Musik]
bis zu 300 arbeiter montieren die
passgenauen teile dann auf der baustelle
das war gustav der fels geheimnis und
machte ihn zum größten ingenieur
seinerzeit
nur 22 monate nach montage beginn ist
der turm fertig er wächst täglich einen
knappen halben meter ende märz 1889
erklimmt er erstmals selbst seinen turm
und ist oben angekommen die französische
flagge
301 meter in zwei jahren zwei monaten
und fünf tagen inklusive fundament für
die damalige zeit ein rekord
tokio vierzehnter juli 2008
spatenstich beim bau des tokyo sky trees
[Applaus]
[Musik]
trotz seiner außergewöhnlichen höhe
musste japanische turm stabil genug sein
um erdbeben und orkanen zu trotzen
gleichzeitig sind die erwartungen in
sachen design sehr hoch
die höhere sicherheit schönheit diese
drei faktoren laufen eigentlich
gegeneinander müssen aber in einklang
gebracht werden die idee der turm ändert
seine form mit zunehmender höhe von
einem dreieck an der basis zu einem
kreis an der spitze
um den sky tree trotz seines komplexen
designs schnell bauen zu können haben
die ingenieure ein cleveres prinzip
innerhalb des stadtkerns stellt ein
automatisiertes logistiksystem sicher
dass die materialien vom boden an die
korrekte stelle im jeweiligen geschoss
gelangen roboter verschweißen die
elemente anschließend präzise und
erschaffen so einen der höchsten und
sichersten türme der welt
die weiterentwicklung des
robotergestützten bauprozesses beim
tokyo sky tree ist legendär und
zukunftsweisend
doch trotz aller automatisierung ohne
menschen geht es nicht
580.000 arbeiter sind am bauprozess
beteiligt
nach drei jahren und acht monaten sind
die arbeiten abgeschlossen
[Musik]
nur wenig schneller als der im
neunzehnten jahrhundert erbaute
eiffelturm
trotz modernster logistiksysteme und
deutlich mehr arbeiten nur ein kleiner
vorsprung
völlig verschiedene designs
baumaterialien und maschinen und dennoch
haben die beiden türme eines gemeinsam
die beeindruckende geschwindigkeit in
der sie entstanden sind
beim bau der beiden türme schrecken
ingenieure und architekten nicht davor
zurück neue wege zu gehen
[Musik]
doch worin unterscheiden sich die
wahrzeichen
was sind ihre features
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ob in paris oder tokio wer den
grandiosen ausblick genießen möchte
nimmt einen der aufzüge zur
aussichtsplattform
heutzutage eine selbstverständlichkeit
aber ende des neunzehnten jahrhundert
sind aufzüge für die breite masse eine
technische neuheit sie gelten sogar als
gefährlich
in den köpfen der leute waren auf züge
noch nicht hundertprozentig ausgereift
dennoch für vista vfl war es undenkbar
dass die besucher über 1600 stufen hoch
steigen er hat eine andere idee wie sie
schneller und müheloser nach oben
gelangen doch er braucht dafür drei
unterschiedliche systeme bis zur ersten
etage ist es einfach die beine der
säulen sind breit und gerade hier reicht
ein konventioneller aufzug aus zwei
große kabinen verkehren auf den bereits
beim bau installierten schienen im nord
und süd pfeiler des turms
[Musik]
doch die starke krümmung der streben von
der ersten plattform aufwärts erfordert
mal wieder eine spezialanfertigung
besucht war eine mischung aus säubern
und aufzug
die aufzug experten von otis entwickeln
eine weltneuheit
zwei riesige hydraulische sailauf züge
folgen der neigung des turms der
personentransport vom zweiten in den
dritten stock ist sogar noch
komplizierter der aufzug muss
schließlich einen höhenunterschied von
160 metern überbrücken
das hatte zu dem zeitpunkt noch keiner
geschafft
auch hier glänzte ingenieur fl wieder
mit einer brillanten idee er halbiert
die fahrstrecke indem er zwei
gegenläufige paar körbe installiert
die beiden kabinen halten sich über ein
seil im gleichgewicht wenn eine kabine
hoch fährt kommt die andere runter
die besucher erhalten auf halber höhe an
steigen dort um und fahren anschließend
bis ganz nach oben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so was hat die welt noch nicht gesehen
[Musik]
insgesamt dauert die fahrt zur spitze
damals zehn minuten das system ist bis
heute weitgehend erhalten nicht zuletzt
deshalb sind die aufzüge des eiffelturms
eine attraktion für sich
[Applaus]
pro jahr legen sie insgesamt 100 3000
kilometer zurück so viel wie zweieinhalb
mal um die erde
die aufzug technik im französischen
eiffelturm ist bahnbrechend und extrem
ausgeklügelt wie sieht es in japan aus
beim tokyo sky tree ist schon allein die
erste aussichtsplattform höher als der
gesamte eiffelturm
350 meter technisch gesehen ist das
reine überwinden von höhe mittlerweile
nicht mehr das grösste problem
heutzutage geht es eher um
geschwindigkeit und effizienz die sechs
aufzüge im tokyo sky tree gehören zu den
schnellsten der welt mit maximal 600
metern pro minute transportieren sie bis
zu 40 personen auf eine höhe von
445 metern
das einzige was diesen hoch
technisierten maschinen in die quere
kommen könnte sind tatsächlich erdbeben
normalerweise bleiben fahrstühle im
katastrophenfall einfach stehen aus
sicherheitsgründen das kann dramatische
folgen haben
beim großen erdbeben 2011 bleiben in 84
geworden tokios die aufzüge stecken
menschen müssen teilweise über neun
stunden in den engen kabinen ausharren
bis rettung kommt
die aufzüge im tokyo sky tree sind daher
mit einem speziellen sicherheitssystem
ausgestattet
erdbeben sensoren zeichnen die
erschütterungen des gebäudes auf und
berechnen die schwingungen der aufzug
seile in echtzeit
bei zu starken erschütterungen kann der
aufzug weiterhin manuell gesteuert
werden
dank dieser technik erreichen die
kabinen auch im katastrophenfall
zumindest noch die nächste etage
diese besonderheit macht ihr aufzüge im
tokyo sky tree zu den sichersten der
welt
in beiden aufzug systemen steckt für
ihre zeit hoch innovative technik welche
sie im weltweiten vergleich zu etwas
ganz besonderem macht
als nächstes im vergleich die
beleuchtung
lichtspektakel prägen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert weltweit
das stadtbild von metropolen sobald die
sonne untergeht funkeln sie um die wette
künstliches licht ist heute nicht mehr
wegzudenken
das war zur erbauungszeit des
eiffelturms ganz anders bereits 1889
existiert die idee den eiffelturm als
eine art leuchtturm einzusetzen von der
spitze aus sollen scheinwerfer die
straßen von paris erhellen und so die
straßenlaternen ersetzen musste das hat
nicht so gut funktioniert weil die den
turm zu beleuchten oder geboren
am abend der einweihung setzen 10.000
gaslampen das neue weltwunder ins licht
die blau-weiß-roten leuchtfeuer gelten
damals als die leistungsstärksten der
welt
ein paar jahre später mitte der
zwanziger startet citroen einen
spektakulären werbecoup neun jahre lang
strahlt der schriftzug des
autoherstellers vom eiffelturm und dient
ganz nebenbei der us flieger legende
charles lindbergh nach seiner
atlantiküberquerung als wegweiser
heute ist die beleuchtung des
eiffelturms topmodell der scheinwerfer
an der turmspitze sendet einen
rotierenden lichtstrahl aus welcher
beeindruckende 80 kilometer weit zu
sehen ist
20.000 lichter funkeln stündlich für
fünf minuten und zu besonderen anlässen
gibt es fulminante lichtshow in vielen
farben
wenn lichtspektakel sind fast schon zu
einer eigenen attraktion geworden aber
aufgepasst die beleuchtung des
eiffelturms ist urheberrechtlich
geschützt heißt ein foto vom
beleuchteten turm ungefragt in sozialen
netzwerken zu posten kann richtig teuer
werden
die beleuchtung des eiffelturms hat sich
immer wieder der zeit angepasst
spektakulär war sie jedes mal
[Musik]
in japan soll der tokyo sky tree nicht
nur der höchste rundfunk turm der welt
werden sondern auch ein symbol seiner
zeit und tokios wahrzeichen nummer eins
die lichtspiele erhält nicht einfach nur
den abendhimmel sie sollen gleichzeitig
vergangenheit gegenwart und die zukunft
japans symbolisieren und das alles
ökologisch korrekt
heutzutage kann nichts mehr installiert
werden ohne an die umwelt zu denken
die lösung für maximale lichtausbeute
bei minimalem stromverbrauch heißt led
[Musik]
hier ist der sky tree vorreiter denn
tatsächlich sind led-lampen erst seit
ein paar jahren auf dem markt
[Musik]
der grund lange zeit gibt es nur rote
und gelb grüne leds
um weiß zu erzeugen und somit das
gesamte farbspektrum abzubilden fehlt
schlicht blaues licht
das war wirklich jahrzehntelang ein
scheinbar unlösbares problem die
revolution auf dem lichtmarkt beginnt in
den 90er jahren in japan drei physiker
erfinden endlich die effiziente blaue
leuchtdiode
2014 erhalten sie dafür sogar den
physik-nobelpreis
der tokyo sky tree ist eines der ersten
bauwerke weltweit das ausschließlich auf
diese neue technik setzt
jede nacht erleuchten über zwei
millionen leds den turm
mit hilfe dieser technik sind nie
dagewesene lichtshows möglich
das beleuchtungssystem spart 43 prozent
der energiekosten im vergleich zu
herkömmlichen leuchtmitteln
[Musik]
der tokyo sky tree nutzt die
umweltfreundlichste lichttechnik der
eiffelturm er findet sich im laufe der
zeit immer wieder neu
spektakuläre lichtshows haben beide
türme drauf
letzter vergleich in der kategorie
features wofür werden die türme
überhaupt eingesetzt
1889 ist der eiffelturm tatsächlich nur
das eingangstor zur weltausstellung ein
prestige objekt ohne praktische nutzen
abgesehen vielleicht vom zweimal täglich
abgefeuerten kanonenschuss der wie ein
glockenturm die website verkündet
also ganz pragmatisch gesehen ist es
kein wunder dass paris den eiffelturm
nach 20 jahren wieder abreisen wollte
doch erbauer gustav fl hat immer wieder
neue ideen den turm am leben zu erhalten
[Musik]
kurz nach der eröffnung beginnt fl sein
architektonisches meisterwerk für
wissenschaftliche experimente zu nutzen
[Musik]
im dritten stock des turms richtet er
ein meteorologisches labor ein der große
vorteil war natürlich dennoch nie
dagewesenen höhenunterschied von 300
metern es folgen beobachtungen zur
schwerkraft und neue aerodynamik
erkenntnisse dank der installation eines
windkanals am fuße des turms
doch die endgültige rettung kommt erst
um die jahrhundertwende
verbietet an den turm für erste rundfunk
experimente zu nutzen und übernimmt auch
gleich die kosten
1903 installiert frankreich erster
antennen auf dem turm drei jahre später
gelingt gustav ii von hier aus die erste
drahtlose telegrafie
das war damals der durchbruch auf dem
gebiet der funktechnologie
die stadt paris erneuert am ersten
januar 1910 die konzession von gustav
der turm darf bleiben beginn der 1920 er
jahre werden vom eiffelturm die ersten
radio sendungen ausgestrahlt später
kommt das fernsehen dazu
in die vielfältigen einsatzmöglichkeiten
haben den turm gerettet
mittlerweile ist der eiffelturm ein
touristenmagnet 7 millionen menschen
besuchen das wahrzeichen der nation
jährlich
was in den 1950 er jahren begann
verändert die welt fernsehen wird das
neue massenmedium schlechthin
1961 gibt es weltweit bereits über 100
millionen
fernsehzuschauer
[Musik]
der bedarf an stabiler
übertragungstechnik steigt immer weiter
da kommt der tokyo sky tree ins spiel
denn er ist ein hochleistungs sendeturm
[Musik]
für die knapp fünf millionen touristen
pro jahr ist das oft nicht so wichtig
sie wollen auf die aussichtsplattformen
und den atemberaubenden blick auf tokio
genießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für einen fernsehturm ist das definitiv
beeindruckend doch das ist nicht alles
im höchsten fernsehturm erforschen
wissenschaftler
blitzeinschläge
luftqualität und
treibhausgase alles wofür man sonst
flugzeuge braucht
hier oben lassen sich auch wolken
untersuchen in 458 metern höhe erfassen
forscher auf dem sky tree größe und
anzahl von feinsten tröpfchen in der
luft mit hilfe dieser daten analysieren
sie wie sich wolken bilden
[Musik]
brüssel ist es natürlich ein
unglaublicher vorteil dieses
beeindruckend hohen turms das ehrgeizige
ziel japans ein wolken radarsystem zu
entwickeln um heftige regenfälle
frühzeitig zu erkennen
doch der tokyo sky tree dient nicht nur
als frühwarnsystem durch seine extrem
sichere bauweise soll der
naturkatastrophen wie erdbeben und
taifune überstehen und unter allen
umständen weiter senden
[Musik]
selbst wenn alles um ihn herum
zusammenbricht soll er weiterhin
funktionieren als katastrophenschutz
einrichtung
deshalb sind in unmittelbarer nähe des
turms ein schutzraum eine lagerhalle mit
note vorräten für 3000 personen und ein
unterirdischer trinkwasserspeicher
fazit der tokyo sky tree ist mehr als
nur ein fernsehturm seine rolle bei
unterschiedlichsten forschungen und im
katastrophenschutz machen ihn absolut
einzigartig
[Musik]
japans mega turm ist von anfang an ein
hightech gigant
der eiffelturm hingegen er findet sich
seit über 100 jahren immer wieder neu
und sendet bis heute
wie sieht es in der letzten kategorie
aus
architektur
beide türme setzen standards
in der ersten runde werfen wir einen
blick auf die ingenieurskunst
oder genauer gesagt das design
die eiffel turm gilt unumstritten als
ikone der architektur warum weil sein
design nicht nur optisch ansprechend
sondern auch das ergebnis genialer
ingenieursarbeit ist
wie kein anderes bauwerk zuvor löst der
eiffelturm eine weltweite turmbau fälle
aus viele davon lehnen sich an das
design des eiffelturms an manche
kopieren es sogar
zu den ersten repliken zählt der 1894
eingeweihte blackpool tower in england
allerdings mit
158 metern deutlich kleiner
1985 folgt der wohl berühmteste nachbau
der tokyo tower in japan mit 333 metern
sogar ein bisschen höher als das
original
nur gut halb so hoch hingegen ist diese
kopie in las vegas sie ist viel jünger
und strahlt erst seit 1999 am legendären
strip
was das design des eiffelturms so
besonders macht ist vor allem der
quadratischen grundriss mit vier
pfeilern ihr abstand voneinander knapp
75 meter
die füße sind exakt nach den
himmelsrichtungen angelegt 16 vertikal
versetzte und in vierer gruppen
zusammengefasst eisenstreben ragen
bogenförmig in den himmel
sie verbinden drei besucher plattformen
auf 57 1 115 und 276 metern
[Musik]
die durchdachte und scheinbar
komplizierte architektur ist
gleichzeitig so simpel das ist genial
der eiffelturm ist nicht nur ein
ingenieurs technischer geniestreich
auch in sachen design stellt er
sämtliche bauwerke seinerzeit in den
schatten und
revolutioniert damit die architektur
weltweit kein anderer turm findet so
viele nachahmer
[Musik]
türme müssen seit dem eiffelturm viel
mehr als nur funktional sein sie sind
gleichzeitig ein wahrzeichen ihrer stadt
und ihres landes jeder will seinen ganz
eigenen welt berühmten turm daher
experimentieren die architekten
heutzutage mit den unterschiedlichsten
formen
[Musik]
design ist heute viel mehr als neuen
look und jedes element hat eine eigene
botschaft
der tokyo sky tree treibt diesen trend
auf die spitze in seiner dreiecksform am
boden spiegelt sich der standort der
turm liegt genau in der mitte eines
dreiecks dass der solider fluss der ak
fluss und die turbo railway bilden
vom dreieck an der basis geht der turm
in 350 metern höhe in eine zylindrische
form über je nach blickwinkel sieht der
tokyo sky tree immer ein bisschen anders
aus ein symbol für einzigartigkeit und
originalität
die silhouette des turms ist von
traditionellen japanischen prinzipien
inspiriert sorry konkave kurven und muri
konvexe wölbungen
von antiken tempeln bis zu den
weltberühmten samurai schwertern die
verbindung von sori und muri ist tief in
der japanischen kultur verankert
[Musik]
die japaner sind waren meisten verbinden
von tradition und moderne von
vergangenheit und zukunft
letztendlich ist der tokyo sky tree viel
mehr als nur ein einfacher turm
allerdings ist er noch zu jung um eine
revolution der architektur für sich zu
beanspruchen
das hat ihm der über 100 jahre alte
eiffelturm zumindest bis heute voraus
nächste runde in der kategorie
architektur
statik wie konnten die erbauer überhaupt
solche bis dahin unüberwindbaren höhen
erreichen die 1000 fuß marke rund 300
meter ist im neunzehnten jahrhundert
eine regelrechte obsession unter
ingenieuren und architekten
es ist vor allem ein wettstreit zwischen
amerika und frankreich wer knackt die
marke als erstes
[Musik]
das problem der baustoff bis ins 19
jahrhundert errichten bauherren ihre
türme vor allem aus holz oder stein
nach je höher man baut desto größere
belastungen muss das material aus halten
beide baustoffe bringen probleme mit
sich
holz ist ab einer bestimmten höhe nicht
stabil genug
stein ist fester aber auch schwerer je
höher der bau desto mehr steigt der
druck auf die unteren schichten
die folge bei 200 metern höhe war
material bedingt schluss
jeder weiß wie der eiffelturm den
höhenrekord geknackt hat das geheimnis
liegt im baumaterial stahl
die statischen eigenschaften von stahl
sind bestechend stabil und
verhältnismäßig leicht
bezogen auf seine größe ist der
eiffelturm ein leichtgewicht mit 10.100
tonnen
dabei ist stahl nicht gleich stahl
verwendet das sogenannte schmiedeeisen
also geschmiedetes eisen
daraus werden auch hufeisen gemacht
christa der kreative umgang mit dem
werkstoff eisen brachte gustave eiffel
unfassbaren ruhm ein man nannte ihn den
eisen zauberer
[Musik]
und das schon vor dem bau des
eiffelturms
beeindruckende konstruktionen wie die
ponte maria pia bei porto oder die gala
beat brücke im französischen
zentralmassiv
zementieren seinen ruf als genialer
konstrukteur
[Musik]
wie zuvor beim brückenbau setzt bei
seinem neuen turm auf nieten
zweieinhalb millionen halten die
bauteile zusammen
leicht und gleichzeitig absolut
wasserdicht verbunden statisch gesehen
ist das die optimale kombination
der eiffelturm auch in sachen statik ein
vorreiter
die kombination aus baustoff- und
verbindungstechnik ist damals einmalig
tatsächlich besteht auch der tokyo sky
tree zum großteil aus stahl kein wunder
je höher der bau desto relevanter ist
das eigengewicht des materials
[Musik]
die bei thermen ist statisch gesehen vor
allem das verhältnis von höhe und breite
entscheidend
beim tokyo sky tree beträgt dieses
verhältnis sage und schreibe neun zu
eins er ist also neunmal höher als breit
das war wirklich eine der größten
herausforderungen beim sky tree
die lösung der toom körper selbst
besteht aus einem filigranen
stahlskelett die tragenden stahlrohre im
unteren bereich des turmes mit einem
durchmesser von 2,3 metern sind zehn
zentimeter dick um ihn zusätzlich zu
stabilisieren befindet sich in seinem
kern eine zylindrische säule aus
massivem stahlbeton
das fazit zum thema statik beiden türmen
liegt das geheimnis letztendlich im
baumaterial gepaart mit der
konstruktionsweise beide sind extrem
stabil
doch wie standhaft ist die architektur
wenn sich die natur einmischt wie sehr
trotzen die türme den naturgewalten
orkane hochwasser erdbeben
naturkatastrophen hinterlassen oft
verheerende schäden und machen vor
nichts halt
die größte gefahr für den eiffelturm
stürme damals gibt es keine erfahrung
mit derart monumentalen bauten die
konstrukteure haben bedenken ob der turm
den wind kräften in 300 metern höhe
trotzen kann
raffl sorgte sich immer um den wind
um das problem in den griff zu bekommen
entwickelt gustave eiffel mal wieder
einen revolutionären neuen ansatz
eifel plate heldin auf nummer sicher bei
seinen berechnungen geht es in linden
mit einem druck von bis zu 400 kilogramm
pro quadratmeter aus die wind kräfte
werden durch die fachwerkkonstruktion
richtung boden geleitet der clou der
verlauf der turm stützen entspricht der
stütz linie also einer gedachten linie
im zentrum des bauwerks hier kommen
vertikale und horizontale kräfte
zusammen
die gitter artige konstruktion des turms
sorgt für zusätzliche stabilität
der wind bläst hindurch ohne großen
druck auf das bauwerk auszuüben
eben selbst bei windgeschwindigkeiten
bis zu 200 kilometern pro stunde frank
die spitze maximal 18 cm
wind macht dem eiffelturm kaum etwas aus
die gitterwerk konstruktion ist extrem
effektiv
wie sieht es beim tokyo sky tree aus
hier sind nicht starke winde die größte
gefahr sondern erdbeben
2000 mal pro jahr erschüttern die
bewegungen der erdplatten japan auf der
einen seite alltag auf der anderen eine
stets drohende gefahr das land liegt auf
dem pazifischen feuerring dort stoßen
vier kontinentalplatten aneinander
vulkanausbrüche
tsunamis alles ist jederzeit möglich und
tokio mit über 30 millionen einwohnern
liegt mitten im gefahrengebiet
eigentlich existiert in japan aufgrund
der extrem hohen tektonischen aktivität
die natürliche 600 meter grenze für
gebäude
der tokyo sky tree überschreitet diese
grenze um 34 meter wie kann das sicher
sein die lösungen finden die ingenieure
in traditionellen bauwerken
[Musik]
japanische pagoden die meisten sind fünf
stück ich und werden anfangs zur
sicheren verwahrung von knochen und
anderen sterblichen überresten
buddhistischer mönche gebaut
die konstrukteure fein jahre lang an der
bauweise bis sie ein erdbebensicheres
system entwickeln durch entkoppelung der
einzelnen elemente
[Musik]
beste idee de erdbeben resistenz
existiert schon seit jahrhunderten
genau dieses wissen machen sich die
architekten des sky tree zu nutzen
das geheimnis liegt in der technologie
des sogenannten schimmer schieres
erschien ein zentraler mittelpfeiler
bildet das herz des turms die
besonderheit er ist nicht fest mit
antennenmast und äußerer stahl struktur
verbunden sondern entkoppelt öldämpfe
puffern die verbindung von beton kern
und stahlskelett der vorteil jedes
bauteil kann unterschiedlich auf
vibrationen reagieren
wären alle teile des turms fest
miteinander verbunden würden sich die
vibrationen über die höhe des gebäudes
vervielfältigen
die technologie zur erdbebensicherheit
macht den skype viel sicherer als jedes
andere gebäude ähnlicher höhe
beide türme sind extrem stabil gebaut
ausgeklügelte systeme und berechnungen
sorgen dafür dass sie noch lange die
naturgewalten trotzen
fazit in sachen architektur
eiffelturm und tokyo sky tree sind
meisterleistungen und haben eine
herausragende sonderstellung im
vergleich zu ihren weltweiten kollegen
mehr als 100 jahre liegen zwischen dem
bau des tokyo sky tree auf den die
japaner zu recht stolz sind
und dem pariser eiffelturm einem der
beliebtesten bauwerke der welt
ob in sachen bau architektur oder
features beide sind mehr als nur sie
sind symbole für ihr land und ihr volk
sie treten die silhouetten ihrer städte
und sind ein magnet für touristen
[Musik]